so tell me how did you get involved with
this project
um this was actually a very
um surprisingly quick process
um John had
um emailed me and
asked to meet up and I was like of
course and then after we met and I read
the script he was like do you want to do
want to be a part of this and I was like
of course it's just it was very simple
um I'm just honored what was it about
the role that really Drew you in
um well actually this is one of the
oldest characters I've played because he
goes from a freshman in high school to a
freshman in college
um so he's 18 by the end of the film uh
and I mean I was drawn to
the complexities of the character
um I mean
he is at his core
like a lot of other characters in in the
way that he's
he's kind and and and
um
loyal and cares about his family and
like he's he's but he but he's a little
self-righteous at times and a little
self-serving and um
you know he even says it in the film
he's like I'm just trying to look out
for myself and he's very he's very clear
about that
um and I I love that about him because
he's very real
and just he experiences a lot of
lost in his life uh with his mother and
then he's close to his father so it's
just
um his history builds up into eventually
it starts to Bubble into anger and he
starts to take it out on other people
towards the end of the film and then
um but he grows and I I love that do you
worry that you're going to be Typecast
as a Stephen King kid
that's fine with me
has has your
um interest or respect for Stephen King
groan as you've played more of his
characters of course
um I had always
known who Stephen King was and
um but never really read his books I
appreciated the movies adapted from his
books but
um but since since working not with him
directly but working on his projects
I've I've read his stuff including his
book on writing which is phenomenal
um because he talks about his his
history and him growing up
um and he's obviously just a master at
what he does can you talk a little bit
about working with Donald Sutherland yes
um
Donald is lovely Donald is
he for me at least just
um
I was very intimidated by him because
he's
he has his presence he has this voice
um and
and this energy about him that
is
is unlike no one else and obviously he's
been doing this for so long so
a part of me wants to
a not annoy him and be impress him
without trying to impress him or just
like you know not make a fool of myself
um so of course I was in my head
um
and acting beside him was amazing
because I was just I was just in awe of
him
and then eventually I learned that he's
just the funniest
most like generous and and and uh kind
human being and um he he took a lot of
time out
to um make me feel comfortable and and
um he gave me a lot of advice
um on the last day of filming he I was
eating lunch and um uh one of The
Producers came over and said Don wants
to see you in his trailer before he
leaves it was his last day and I was
like of course I gotta run over there so
I I ran over there and he basically told
me to
um
uh fortunately he told me to to never
stop acting which is amazing and he was
like
go to college study literature like I
did
um and then eventually he sent me a lots
of plays to to study and go over so he
you know that showed that he really
cared it was very special can you talk a
little bit about the bullying scene
um was that difficult to kind of get
into or was it
I don't know traumatic or anything not
necessarily but it um
Cyrus
um the actor who played uh Kenny
Yankovic's the one in the sweetest
people I know like he he's like a puppy
he's lovely and also very very talented
um and we got along really well
and um
I mean the the physical aspect of it was
a little hard we're just working with
stunt coordinators
um and but the thing that I loved when I
read the script is that it wasn't
necessarily
I mean he's obvious He's a Bully but
um he's also just a very troubled person
it wasn't like a one-dimensional bully
character a jock or whatever he's just
someone who
I mean he crack talks about it in the
film he's someone who just decided not
to like him and he's just drawn to
to violence and anger because he he was
raised a certain way
um and then eventually Craig learns oh
he's not just a bully like he has a
family too that uh
is go it misses him and loves him so
that's what I kind of I loved about it
those three-dimensional
um and it wasn't too hard to get into
and what do you have coming up for
yourself
what other projects do you have
um I don't know what I can say I don't
know and I never know I'm so bad at this
um
just Mr Harkins coming out okay
um all right well thank you so much I
really appreciate it thank you very much